take a break
if you find yourself stuck on something
if you find yourself unable to make
progress on a project that you're
working on
take a break
because often if you just try to ram
something through you're not going to
get the results that you're looking for
and if you take 10 minutes
go away from it and come back
you'll often be refreshed and be able to
solve the problem
the two quick stories for you that
happened to me recently so
yesterday jason who's helping me with my
new website and all the branding that
goes with it he's working on some coding
problems something on the website some
some bug that he's trying to work
through and he couldn't find a solution
and he's spending like an hour on this
thing and and i just see him on the
computer like uh rubbing his eyes and
unable to make progress on this thing
and so
he does a smart thing and he goes and he
takes a break
he goes out goes for a walk gets some
food comes back and within five minutes
of sitting down again he solves it
and this happens to me
so much and i don't know what it is
about the human condition that that that
allows us to to do this but i often find
myself with these kinds of problems and
and i may come back to it the same day
or maybe it's the next day but the
solution often comes really quickly
after taking a break so again if you
find yourself pounding away on something
and you're just not making progress you
just can't figure out what the problem
is
take a break even like 10-15 minutes and
come back to it another quick example is
uh in salsa dancing
i love salsa dancing i love teaching
people how to dance as well and i was
working with a student
teaching her how to do some turns
and
she just wasn't getting it
and so i said okay you know what it's
okay it's okay we'll come back to it
we'll move on to other stuff and it was
it was an hour that was with her
and we did other moves and at the end of
the hour came back and did the turn
again
and she got it
and so the first example was you know
programming business related this was
salsa dancing personal new skill any
time you're trying to figure something
out if you're if you're doing it over
and over and over again and it's just
not working out for whatever reason i
don't know why this happens
but
if you're not making progress stop
and come back to it later that day or
the next day
and you'll amaze yourself with how
you're able to quickly make progress
and think why didn't i think of that
before
so take a break
believe for those of you watching you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below it always makes me want to do
more for you and please leave a comment
underneath let me know what you think i
really love seeing the comments come in
they they make my day they're so
important to me every day it makes me
keep going and doing these for you so
please leave a comment and if you have a
question leave it below i'll do a video
response thank you guys i'll see you
soon